assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and friends welcome to
a another livestream this one is going
to be a
very very interesting one today i'm
being joined by her brother hamza
islamic bro well salam rahmatullahu
very very good and very excited as well
bro this is going to be a very important
live stream
and the reason is bro because
you know throughout history christian
missionaries have made a
objective and goal of their lives to
misrepresent islam through
through poor translations of the quran
you know
misrepresenting certain concepts and
ideas about the deen
and now we find individuals even today
in the 21st century
respected individuals professors who are
again misrepresenting some core
fundamentals of islam just to
paint that negative perception now in
particular what we're going to be
discussing today
is a clip by dr william lane craig which
has been circulating again i
you remind you the one that she told me
is quite an old clip
that was there a few years ago but it's
been recirculating again
where he speaks about allah and he
speaks about the love of allah mentioned
in the quran and compares it to
the love of god in christianity now
we're going to go through the whole clip
and we're going to break it down in a
second
and we're going to get your thoughts on
it and highlight why craig's view
is incorrect it's either that he hasn't
read the quran or understood it properly
or it's
he's it's that he's deliberately
misrepresenting whichever the of the two
is we're not going to make that we're
not going to make that judgment but
we're going to put the facts on the
table for people to see for themselves
inshallah
but before we do that hamza why don't
you give us a summary bro
of what we're going to be discussing
yeah before i do that i would like to
basically say that you know we have to
have some form of intellectual humility
and gratitude as well at the same time
because dr william craig has been
responsible
for reviving powerful
islamic philosophical arguments for the
existence of god
and i personally have benefited
a lot from his work and he is referenced
in my book the divine reality and
for that we should show some form of
intellectual humility
and also gratitude
notwithstanding it's very important to
highlight very carefully that
i remember dr william named craig
mentioning
the concept of god in islam and
christianity i think
12 years ago and it and it struck me
and i've always wanted to respond in
some way
and alhamdulillah you gave me this
opportunity may allah bless you
and we can do this together and the
first thing i like to say is
dr william lane craig has obviously not
studied the islamic intellectual
spiritual tradition properly
he hasn't gone into the tafasir
the exegetical works of the verses that
he is referring to
he in my view hasn't studied
the normative classical creeds
and the commentaries associated with
them concerning the conception of the
divine reality
in islam and
this is problematic because
he's been willing to be very nuanced
and philosophical when it comes to
philosophical ideas
existential ideas theo philosophical
ideas
but when it comes to the divine and
islamic tradition
he basically regurgitates
a form of narrative that echoes someone
who's been on google and does some basic
searches
and this has to change and hopefully by
the end of this
video it would evoke something within
him to engage positively with the
islamic intellectual spiritual tradition
and hopefully engage with us in order
for us to have a discussion on this
topic
so the thing i really want to say is
this
there is an argument against dr
craig's argument and it's based on
three premises two premises and a
conclusion number one
for god to be maximally loving
he has to be maximally forgiving
number two the biblical god is not
maximally forgiving three
therefore the biblical god is not
maximally loving and we're gonna unpack
this i think the first premise doesn't
have to be discussed because if someone
is maximally loving
they have to be maximally forgiving
repeat those three again just so
everyone's on this
yeah so premise number one
for god to be maximally loving
it entails or he has to be maximally
forgiving
and this is not a controversial premise
because forgiveness
is the language of love number two
and this is the controversial premise
the biblical god
according to william lane craig is not
maximally forgiving
number three therefore the biblical god
is not maximally loving
now why why is the biblical god not
maximally loving
so not maximally forgiving and therefore
he's not max me loving
it's very simple number one god's love
according to a biblical narrative
is rooted in suffering god's love in a
biblical narrative
is rooted in forgiving humanity
outside of the relation of the human
being and the divine
and it's based on an event that
supposedly had to happen
and not only that it's based on you
accepting the event
actually happened it's not rooted in
your relation to the divine your heart
being sincere and asking forgiveness to
the divine
construct construct contrastingly
the islamic conception is
based on maximal forgiveness because it
just takes a human heart
to repent to the divine and this is why
in the christian tradition because of
john 3 16 because of the sacrifice and
the atonement
what the biblical narrative is saying
it's saying that human sin
limits god's mercy
so from this point of view william named
craig
i think he's basically being a little
bit of a sophist here
because if you really understand the
christian doctrine
then you have to admit that god is not
maximally forgiving if
not if he is not maximally forgiving
then how can he be
maximally loving because
to be maximally loving entails maximum
forgiveness as well
so that's the summary of what we're
going to be talking about we're also
going to be talking about the fact that
actually
have you not read that allah says about
himself that he is
he is the loving that's one of his names
which comes from the arabic
arabic word wood which means the loving
that is giving he is excessively loving
his love is so pure and so maximal that
it's even greater than any form of love
you can imagine
uh in in a worldly sense even a mother's
love because a mother she
needs to love god doesn't need anything
yet he loves
imagine how pure and maximal his love is
so have you not read that god is loving
have you not read that allah is a
man and which means the merciful
now interestingly from a linguistic
point of view indicates
a very intense loving mercy a boiling
over type of mercy and immediate mercy a
mercy that's so powerful that no one can
stop
and allah says that his mercy
encompasses everything
the sinner the evil doer the believer
the non-believer allah's intense mercy
and mercy in the english language is the
synonym for love
encompasses everything so
why are you misrepresenting the islamic
tradition because there are different
levels of love in the islamic tradition
different levels of mercy you have rahma
you have a rahim
you have muawadha you have all of these
different levels and they have specific
understandings
anyone who studied the islamic tradition
would have known this right
so you can't say god's god is not
his mercy is not universal his mercy is
um what would he what did he say
impartial and his mercy's
uh uh uh conditional that's not true
because allah says his
intense mercy is impartial because it's
for everybody it's universal encompasses
everything
and it's also unconditional allah is
merciful to you even if you disobey him
and as i said mercy is a cinnamon
synonym for love in the islamic
tradition
so this is the kind of summary of the
things that we want to talk about
he actually overlooks this you know he's
just referring to
well let's just speaking about okay he
loves so and so he doesn't love songs
from the quran and he completely
neglects the aspect of mercy
and our mercy entails love it's a part
of love like you said
and and what we're going to see as we
discuss this bro is that beautiful
balance between the love and mercy of
allah
which works in such a magnificent and
perfect way
from the perspective of what this life
is all about we're going to see this too
and it's it's
and if anything we're going to see how
the conception of love and mercy of
allah in islam
in and being in line with the objective
allah created reality
for is perfect it's completely coherent
one thing i want to mention though isn't
it very interesting that
you know is it is it maximum love
to create human beings with inherent sin
whereas human beings in islamic
tradition
they're created with inherent goodness
based on the fitra i mean
case closed that's like a philosophical
mic drop right there
yeah your conception of divine has
already
put a distance between humanity and the
divine because of sin because the wages
of sin is death right
god is so holy according to the
christian tradition
that's why you need an external type of
sacrifice this is not the islamic
tradition
you don't need that you are you're born
into goodness
not into inherent evil inherent sin
so from this point of view just on that
perspective
what is more loving like god is making
it harder for everybody else according
to the biblical narrative
that not only are you going to be
created but you're going to be created
distant from me
inherently you're going to have sin
which distance
which distance the human being from the
divine but allah he creates a human
being
in goodness which we call the innate
disposition
that is based on proton knowledge that
has proton knowledge within it which is
god is reality is worthy of worship and
we have a basic level of goodness
let's proceed so bro before i proceed
let me clarify something to the audience
some people have had an objection with
me titling the video hums of daughters
versus william lane craig
now i didn't say it was a debate
obviously i wanted to make the title a
bit spicy
uh just so we can get the interest and
inshallah this will lead to
a proper discussion a face-to-face
discussion between maybe hamza and
william dr william lane craig
after this goes live inshallah um so
yeah try to clarify that i never said it
was a debate i did clarify on the
community section of the page that this
is a discussion it's a response to the
reaction video
so apologies to anyone that uh took the
wrong end of the stick with
in regards to the title but now
inshallah let's continue let's play the
clip bro you told me when to stop and
then we'll analyze each section as we go
through
i think the question is better reworded
by saying
is the concept of god in islam
the same as the concept of god in
christianity
do we have the same understanding of god
and there i argued that they are worlds
apart
that the concept of god and islam and
christianity
is very very different and one of the
principle ways in which they are
different is
that the muslim concept of god i believe
is morally defective it is a morally
defective
vision of who god is as
the greatest conceivable being a morally
perfect being
god must be all loving
and this is exactly what the bible
teaches the bible teaches that god
loves sinners his love is impartial
it is universal it is unconditional
and this is a world of difference from
the god of the quran
according to the quran god does not love
sinners he does not love unbelievers he
is an
enemy to unbelievers god
in the quran only loves those who
first loved him okay stop here
okay yeah so as we said
you know he he he basically
misrepresents
allah in the islamic tradition god in
the islamic tradition
where he's basically saying that god
doesn't love
sinners he doesn't love those who you
know disobey him the wrongdoers
now we have to understand what does he
mean by love here because as we said
mercy is also a synonym for love so does
god have mercy for the disbelievers
absolutely we've mentioned this in the
beginning allah says his mercy
encompasses everything
does god have mercy for wrongdoers
absolutely
now but i also want to challenge his
conception of love
what type of love are you now talking
about because there are different types
of love
the islamic tradition is very nuanced
right we have
many names meanings words for love
and they have a particular reality now
you know it's easy to use the english
language say lava would you actually
mean
so i would i would actually ask him that
question because i need to think about
this bro
and and i wrote this down on my phone
let me just unlock the phone
now is it maximal love
to love everything the same that's the
big question
yes and this is the problem because it
is not maximally loving to love
everything the same
can i love goodness the same way as i
love badness
evil in actual fact would it be loving
for me to love evil
i mean let's think about that right so
think about this
perfect love is to love goodness
to love mercy to love kindness to love
connecting with one's creator to love
peace and in it follows that if you love
something you have to hate its opposite
which means you have to hate evil you
have to hate the opposition to love
you have to hate malevolence you have to
hate polytheism
you have to hate chaos and destruction
are you saying
it's perfect maximal love
to love that which is a barrier to love
i mean this doesn't make sense because
if if you love everything
then you really don't love anything at
all
yeah you you've actually summarized it
better than the while where i was
summarizing it
so that's the feel for this yes the
second point is on terms
like god doesn't love the sinner well
what does that really mean
does it mean god doesn't love the
intrigue the human being what makes a
human being the intrinsic value of the
human being
absolutely not what does allah say about
the human being
he has aurora he has a soul he has a
fitra and in that fitra there is
goodness that innate disposition has
goodness
does god hate that no let me tell you
what god doesn't like
god doesn't like the way the human being
has identity
identified themselves by virtue of their
state of being i know this is a bit
philosophical but you have to understand
this
so god doesn't like how we've identified
ourselves by virtue of our state of
being
meaning how we relate to ourselves how
we relate to others and how we relate to
the creator
so if my relation to myself and my
relation to others and my relation to
the creator
is not good is evil why would god
like that that's not an expression a
match of maximum perfection
yes and even though goku would not love
that he still has another type of love
if you like which is he
still has mercy for the one who relates
to himself
relates to others and relates to the
divine in an evil way
so this is a nuanced discussion and
wouldn't mean craig unfortunately did
not give islam
jew justice especially since you know he
is grateful for the likes of ali ghazali
the 11th century theologian and what
baffles me habibi yeah
imran what baffles me ali ghazali
himself he wrote his ihea
his compendium sorry his revival of the
religious sciences
in the 36 volume what is he right about
he writes about muhammad love intimacy
contentment with allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and that book he talks about he affirms
allah is
loving and he loves and they can be a
loving relationship
between creation and the creator
that's his own teacher the william lane
creek's teacher
ali ghazali wrote about this you didn't
have to go too far to understand that
allah is
loving and he says that his mercy
encompasses everything
so from that point of view i would even
say that the way his understanding god's
love is not maximally perfect
it's absolutely bro and just let me just
i guess paint that piece
in a slightly different way so we can
really get the point across to people
it's like it's what we're saying is from
the islamic perspective allah's
maximally perfect love is in line with
his names and attributes number one
and number two it's in line with the
objective that he's created this world
for
allah tells us for example that he
created life and death to test which of
us is best in deeds
therefore god has created us in this
world he's made us agents with free will
and he wants us to do good and stay away
from evil now if god has
created us for that reason then why
would this very same god who is claiming
is maximally perfect and makes me loving
at the same time express his love to
creation in a way which undermines that
whole project
because if he loves if he loves the
sinner or the hitler as much as he loves
the mother teresa or the saint
well then where is the objective where
is the where is the motivation for the
the saint to continue to be good and to
continue on that path and where where is
the motivation bro for the
the the the sinner and the hitler to
leave the sin and to become
good right i really believe
when allah says he does not love the
disbeliever for example in the third
chapter of the quran
verse 32 where he says he does not love
the disbeliever this in a way
is acts as a motivation for the
disbeliever to
leave that state like you mentioned and
adopt the state of
absolute belief right and not just that
it also means that it doesn't mean
though that
allah doesn't have another intense mercy
for the disbeliever of course allah has
intense mercy for the disbeliever
because remember we said there's many
grades of mercy and love in the islamic
tradition it's very newest but bro
you've you've opened a massive can of
worms philosophical ones which is
amazing not for us
for the dr craig conception of theology
moral duties don't make sense anymore
yes because what is that that pressing
ought that we ought to do something if
allah loves the sinner
everybody in that way then
you know in the christian tradition i'm
fine i'll go kill a thousand people
right and i just believe that jesus
sacrifices his life for me no problem
then i'm okay as you said yesterday
it's a form of you tell me yeah
religious nihilism that was
[Music]
which is absolutely really really really
powerful so
yeah but also also bro you know when i
and this is another way i want people to
think of it when allah says he does not
love the disbeliever
this is allah's love being expressed to
the disbeliever in a way
because it's his loving mercy which
makes the disbeliever think oh my god my
god does not love me
it hits him deep inside his fitrah and
this will encourage him to rectify him
that's a very good point
you could articulate this way as well so
say say a disbeliever someone who
doesn't who rejects the truth is
listening to this
so allah has intense mercy for you
but you won't have a the the
relationship of special love with him
unless you accept the truth and you
accept the fact that he's the only deity
worthy of worship and that muhammad
the final prophet that should be
motivating because it's not
it's not from that point of view that
you are discarded intrinsically as a
human being
but the way you've identified yourself
and how you relate to yourself
and others and allah is something that
is not loved at all
and if you want to be in a state of
being that is love and you enter to that
loving relation with allah
then you have to do x y and z so yeah
absolutely absolutely so
i think we should just going back on the
point that if you love everything
the same you don't love anything at all
yeah you've undermined the whole human
project from that perspective
and and that in itself would be a a sign
that
well you in a way you'll be claiming
that the maximally perfect being is not
maximally perfect
yeah that was the way he expressed his
love to creation yeah because yeah a
maximum perfect being doesn't love
everything the same
yeah and and and yes does the maximum
perfect being have
mercy for everything absolutely just
like allah says he has mercy for
everything the sinner the evil doer the
believer
but does allah have that special love
for everything the same of course not
because if that's the case you don't
really love anything at all
because as we mentioned maximal perfect
love means that you love goodness
and therefore you should hate the
opposite of that which is
evil so from that point of view i think
his
assumption is false maybe we should
continue the video
let's continue let me play me a second
that his love rises no higher than the
sort of love that jesus said
tax collectors and sinners exhibit
they love those who love them and that's
the kind of love
that the god of the quran exhibits
so the quran assures us of god
it's just so stop by this sorry and the
this we have to hold we we have to just
say no here this this is this is almost
uh
cheeky how can you say the god
of islam his love is like the love of
the tax collector the sinner what we've
said already
undermines that because god's mercy and
mercy is a synonym of love he's intense
mercy's for everything the sinner
the evildoer and the good one but i want
to mention something here
in actual fact he is a victim of his own
criticism
why because remember maximum love enters
maximum forgiveness
good in the biblical tradition is not
maximally forgiving
his forgiveness in other words the way
he expresses his love
is worse than any type of human
forgiveness
bro if if i did you wrong and you said
to me
i would only forgive you if someone's
son is sacrificed
and you have to believe that event
happened yeah
and by you accepting that event i will
forgive you
is that forgiveness well that's not
that's not adequate for limited human
beings how can you apply that to the
creator of the heavens
thank you very much this is what you
call a mic drop philosophically it's not
mike it's a pen
but you get my point yes i think what
craig has done here
is philosophically theologically
spiritually
unacceptable yeah it's it's it's
bordering
literally a joke and it's unfortunate
that you would and this is one of the
things that really shocked me bro
was someone of his caliber would would
would make such statements publicly
uh not doing his research you know that
and you see this over and over again and
that's what shocking is fun
but anyway let's finish off what you're
saying let me play the rest of the clip
for you
dad's love for the god-fearing
and the good doers but he has no love
for sinners and unbelievers the
quran says that god does not love the
very people
that john 3 16 says
god loves so much that he sent his only
son
to die for them while we were yet
enemies
christ died for us so
this is over here bro yep
okay so john 3 16 that god loves us so
much that he basically sacrificed his
only son for us right
now there's another dimension to this
which doesn't
directly relate to what we're talking
about but it's still very significant
and important because it
it you know john 3 16 is supposed to be
this amazing thing and that you know the
christians have a monopoly on a loving
relationship with the divine
i am sorry this is not the case at all
john 3 16
actually shows that there is no maximum
forgiveness and maximal love in the
biblical tradition
with regards to the conception of the
divine why am i saying this
because if if god sacrifices son
for human sin then isn't me not
believing in christianity
a sin me being a muslim isn't that a sin
so by virtue of that i should be okay
right yep didn't jesus sacrifice
wasn't he sacrificed for me as well yeah
me being a muslim is that
sinful according to the christian
tradition mainstream biblical
christianity would say
iman hamza you know you guys are sinners
because one you have inherent sin and
you don't follow jesus you follow islam
which
to many christians would say it's not
the truth
and that's fine but then i would say
well didn't jesus die and get sacrificed
for me for this sin if they say yes
then do i have to accept jesus they will
say no no no no
because it's a gift you have to accept
the gift
you have to accept they actually
happened but for me
doesn't that really devalue the
intrinsic nature of the sacrifice right
yeah going back to craig's original
point god's love must be just across the
board equal and the same at all times
yeah that should apply to you as well
it should apply to the manifestation of
his love which is the sacrifice
if the manifestation of his love which
is the sacrifice doesn't have intrinsic
value
because it's also contingent on me
accepting it
which is a historical event which is
based on a text that is historically
inaccurate has textual uh integrity
problems x y and z
then how is that maximal love
and and how does that make the event so
special when now
not only must the event happen but i
have to acknowledge
the event and accept the event at the
same time
so i would say that's in some way
obviously needs more theological and
philosophical unpacking
but in some way it really diminishes
what you're saying about john 3
16 and in actual fact let's go back to
the whole forgiveness
maximum love and tells maximal
forgiveness well how is this maximally
forgiving
he is well firstly he's not even
maximally just
right because he is blaming someone else
he is blaming someone that doesn't
deserve the blame
and he is torturing and he is
sacrificing someone
that didn't that doesn't deserve the the
torturing and the sacrifice
so how is that maximal forgiveness and
maximal justice
the other thing is it's not maximal
forgiveness because the forgiveness
of me as a human being is contingent on
an event outside of my relation to the
divine
and it's contingent on me accepting it
but with regards to the islamic
tradition maximal forgiveness
is manifested itself why because it just
requires me and my heart to do
tawba is to turn back to god
to ask for his forgiveness i don't need
a sacrifice outside of me
and because the wages of sin is death
sin is so
bad that you know you have to have some
kind of blood sacrifice yeah
which really the biblical tradition is
saying that god that human sin
limits god's mercy and that's and that's
not the islamic tradition
so which is more a loving and forgiving
god
god which one is why and this is why
muslims
should talk about this morning we don't
unfortunately because we have a very
deep
loving type of tradition and it's
manifested in our history i want to read
something to you bro just very quickly
yeah
uh it's actually a historical narrative
it's based on a jewish poet
right a jewish poet you know our jewish
cousins
yeah let me tell one of our jewish
cousins what he said
brothers and sisters while hamza is
bringing it up
yeah sure if you have any questions
please hold off i'll tell you guys we're
gonna do questions at the end inshallah
uh so just repost them if you've posted
them already and we'll address them in
china make sure to share this
on your social medias on your lives
wherever you wherever you can share this
inshallah so other people get access to
this too inshallah
come bro sorry so in the christian
tradition the holy spirit is supposed to
be working right
in you know in the in the present tense
and throughout history
but every time the christians have
always been in power especially the
medieval catholic church
it's it's it's not being very loving at
all i mean
we don't have to talk about when
christianity was in power what happened
yeah
look what happened in uh in spain we
know what happened in spain what was it
called it was called the
uh forgot the name for it the the
inquisition
right killing the jews and the muslims
right and the jews had to go to
enstable and turkey and the jewish rabbi
he says come to the land of the turks
rich are the fruits of the earth we live
in freedom and peace right kind of thing
so every time you know the christian
tradition
or the church or the holy spirit has
been manifesting itself politically
right throughout the ages
it has been bloodshed and killing of
minorities and stuff what's going on
here
and it's interesting that a famous
jewish shade sage and poet
abraham ibn ezra he wrote the following
when he was living
i believe under the islamic influence
islamic authority he said
the muslims sing of love and passion
the christians of war and revenge
the greeks of wisdom and devices the
indians of parables and riddles
and the israelites songs and praises to
the lord of the hosts
so you know poetry is like a mirror of
what's happening from a historical
perspective
and the other thing i want to say is we
had our
kind of saintly figures our pious
predecessors our pious masters
especially in the early
three generations the love of god loving
god was an act of worship
right because worshiping allah means
what to know him to love him to obey him
and to direct and singulate all acts of
worship to god alone
and there was a famous uh scholar if you
like uh
it was a woman a sheikha her name is
rabia
al-adawiyah she wrote a view for poem
and she wrote it about the love of of of
allah it's very moving she said
two ways i love thee selfishly
and next as worthy is of thee
to selfish love that i do not
say think on thee with every thought tis
purest love when thou dost raise
to veil to my adoring gaze not mind the
praise
in that or this thine is the praise in
both
i wish it's a really powerful goosebumps
and and it's it's throughout our
tradition we've had
scholarly people pious people especially
the early three generations
talking about the love of the divine
talking about all of these amazing
things so
it's very important to understand that
the idea of god's love and us
loving god has manifested itself
throughout history
through our poetry throughout our
literature i mentioned al ghazali when
he talks about divine love
what about the student of ibin tamiya
when he basically wrote you know he's
called the heart surgeon and i'm not
talking about medical
or we're talking about spiritual heart
he talks about the love of allah
right and being close to allah and
loving him you know
it's an aspect of the key aspect of
worship to have ikhlas which means
sincerity to do the act of worship for
allah alone
and one aspect of the class is due to do
it because he's worthy of it and to do
it because you love
him right so love it permits our
tradition you know if parents are
tradition so
yeah it's just unfortunate that you know
people as popular you know
they should have an epistemic duty yes
an intellectual duty to at least
allow the tradition to speak for itself
from that point yeah and broad honestly
like when you think about the
just the mercy of allah even to the
sinner the one that's done all this evil
and wrong bro
allah's loving mercy encompasses them
allah reminds them allah calls them back
allah encourages them by telling them
that he does not love them
you know allah encourages them by
telling them who he does love
allah gives them time on this earth bro
he doesn't just kill them or take their
life immediately as soon as they commit
a sin or do something
and interestingly that is a
manifestation of intense mercy
and as i said mercy is a cinnamon for
love in the english language so allah
has a tense mercy for you
that he would say to you your state of
being how you relate to yourself
others and how you relate to god is
something that he does not love
subhanallah so what would make you think
i need to state change my state of being
yes as simple as that and bro and all of
this look how beautifully it's in line
with the objective of this existence as
well that allah is not creating a
situation now by some sort of sacrifice
which
which brings into question his justice
you know brings into question his uh his
forgiveness
it all just pans out in such a beautiful
and coherent way subhanla
you know thinking about it absolutely
let's let's finish
let's finish off if he's not finished
already he's pretty much finished but
let's finish off what he was what he was
saying each other
huge difference between the god of the
quran
and the god of the bible the heavenly
father revealed by jesus
love sinners loves unbelievers
wants him to come to him his love is
universal impartial
uh and unconditional but
the god of the quran his
love is partial it is
selective and um it has to be earned
it is conditional only those who earn it
will receive it so this is a vastly
different conception of god so
i would agree with those who say that
the god of
muhammad is not the god of jesus christ
he's
not the god of the bible okay so in fact
i would say
yep yeah well he would we've already
dealt with those points
uh just to go back on the point when he
says the god of islam his
love is partial selective and earned
again that's not true
god's intense mercy and remember mercy
is a cinnamon of love in the english
language god's mercy is impartial it's
for everybody
sinner and and believer disbeliever good
doer et cetera
it's not selective sorry hamza can you
just repeat what craig said because i
don't think the guys could hear the last
year yes so basically what he said he
said the god in islam
his love is partial selective and has to
be earned
and i'm saying but we already dealt with
that because mercy
allah being the intensely merciful
mercy is a synonym for love and allah
says that his mercy encompasses
everything so it's not partial
it's not selective it's for everyone and
everything good person bad person
believe a disbeliever
and it's not earned because you could
reject him you could live a life of
disobeying him
and allah is still enveloping you in his
intense
powerful immediate mercy because that's
what al-rahman means and interestingly
the word al-rahman shares the same root
as the root for
the womb right and you know the womb
holds the baby and the mother
what kind of love does she have for the
baby and this echoes a prophetic
tradition where the prophet muhammad
upon him bp said
that you know allah has more affection
for you
than your mother's subhanallah case
closed i don't know what creek is
reading
is craig reading the same tradition is
he reading the same quran
is he reading the same intellectual
spiritual tradition has he studied the
islamic theology properly
so what i want to say to him is this why
don't you accept this warm intima in
invitation it's going to be warm it's
going to be a dialogue it's not going to
be
hopefully arrogant and excessive it's
going to be just two people speaking
or as many people as you want come
online
for a live discussion with sapience
institute
let's have a discussion on the concept
of god in islam and the concept of
god in the islamic in the christian
tradition
it's time that we had a conversation
about this it's time that we don't talk
past each other
it is time that we articulate our case
for the concept of
the of god in our traditions in a warm
intellectual
and in in in a compassionate way uh with
wisdom
and you know without talking over each
other we're having a nice friendly
discussion just like
what you had with you know a popular
youtube atheist cosmic skeptic
i'm sure you could do that with someone
who you know
is of the abrahamic faiths let's have
that discussion it's time that we had
discussion on this particular point
and to do it in a way that is edifying
because maybe we've said something a
little bit wrong today maybe we've
misrepresented the christian tradition
maybe whatever the case may be we can
actually learn from each other from that
point of view which is
very powerful and very interesting uh
notwithstanding
there is another approach to dealing
with this issue which brother adnan
rasheed if you go to brother adnan
rasheed's youtube channel
he's actually dealt with this in a
different way it was more of a you know
well let's see if god is loving because
look at the biblical tradition what it
says about
killing the unbelievers and all of these
things right
and he uses that he uses he uses a
texture approach
so if someone's interested in that
approach please go to adan richie's
youtube channel for you to
learn from that approach as well that's
probably not the particular approach
that i'm used to
because that's not my learning i'd line
us an expert on these things masha allah
my thing is more creed theology theo
philosophy that's why we've addressed it
in this way
but i think both approaches are quite uh
complementary and what's very
interesting i said to adman i said to
him
you you went for the jugular and you
spoke about the elephant in the room at
the same time
but yeah so so i think this is it i
think we've uh
we've we've addressed uh uh professor
william craig
you know we thanked him in the beginning
for for for some aspects of his work
but you know we had to address it the
way that we did and hopefully
you know this warm inter invitation is
open
and if you if he wants to his team wants
to contact us
we will reach out but if his team wants
to contact us just go to info
at sapience institute.org
s-a-p-i-e-n-c-e
institute.org and yeah absolutely
and you know recently william dr william
craig has been
quite he's been a bit more vocal in
regards to islam and been talking about
islam a lot more i don't know if it's
influenced by david wood or whatever the
case is
um but definitely look if you're gonna
i thought david wood was finished well
he's he's finished but he's still
trying to as per as per
um so yeah it's it's it's an open
invitation you know the
objective one of the objectives behind
doing this live was one number one first
and foremost to clarify
you know how we understand and try to to
the best of our ability to do justice to
how we understand the love of allah from
the islamic tradition
and secondly was to invite dr william
craig for an official debate it could be
online we know he's done it before with
the cosmic skeptic etc online
so there shouldn't be any excuses or
issues um so
definitely you know and another thing
brothers and sisters this is hamza
there's about 300
and there was about 350 people watching
this live there's about 306 now
so brothers and sisters are like it's
it's i would say it's a responsibility
upon every single one of us right
now to share this or tweet this to dr
william lane craig
or his team and and get this out there
so we can have that dialogue let's make
him deliver
his content and at the very least bro at
least he gets to learn about what islam
says in regards to the love of god
yes and one thing one thing i want to
mention is to the muslims right
you know we have to take responsibility
as well
we haven't you know collectively
especially in the west revived
this understanding of worship that
includes
god's love it's very important for us to
resurrect this classical mainstream
islamic understanding of the divine
nature that is
the loving and how we relate to that
because
worshiping allah enters knowing him but
also loving him
and obeying him and that includes being
humble before him and directing all acts
of worship to him alone
we need to establish a loving
relationship with
the reason i'm saying that because it
would change the way
we become in the world and who we are so
i've i've been so shocked especially
when i became muslim around 18 years ago
that christians can say that they have a
loving relationship with the lord
muslims don't have a loving relation
with the lord and i'm thinking
how on earth can they even say this and
that's because maybe we don't speak
about this enough
because if any christian i'm talking to
my christian brothers and sisters in
humanity now
if you understood who allah is that he
doesn't require anything external to the
way you relate to god in order to god
for god to forgive you
right you know it doesn't require an
external sacrifice
doesn't require you to believe that that
sacrifice actually even happened just
your heart to turn to him
that's all that's required this is
maximal forgiveness this is maximal love
the way you worship allah is not through
his son or through a pope or a book
it's actually yourself salah the five
daily prayers comes from the root word
to connect
we want to connect directly to the
divine this is a direct loving
relationship
a direct loving relationship jesus is
not the bridge between
you and the father yes so-called father
but rather is this your heart
and allah your heart and allah let your
heart gaze
to the love of allah subhanallah it
become closer to allah by following the
prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi he wasn't because allah says in
the quran if you love allah
then follow me meaning follow muhammad
sallam and allah would love you
and forgive your sins and this is a
special type of love allah has that
intense mercy for you but if you want
that
special type of love you want that love
then you
need to follow the way to him which is
worshipping allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala because
because you know worshiping allah
subhanahu wa to allah
in the kind of muhammadan way in the way
of the sunnah of the process
is the way to connect to him and that
doesn't require anything external
doesn't require his son it is you
directly to allah so what is
who has more of a loving relationship
right from that point of view because
it's
it's it's all there it's just you your
heart and allah
so you know i i i want christians to
study this tradition
um to understand this tradition to
understand who allah
is and maybe you should play a final
video because it's very interesting that
william lane craig
was saying that god and the quran hates
so and so but what does actually the
bible say i mean you've become a victim
of your own criticism watch this video
guys
and put the volume up yeah give me a
second let me just
well basically yeah carry on until you
get it ready it's in proverbs that
the the god of the bible actually hates
seven people or seven things at least
let me put the nail in this coffin real
tight
god hates a liar
proverb chapter 6 verse 16 says
these six things doth the lord hate
yea seven are an abomination unto him
a proud look a lying tongue and hands
that
shed innocent blood a heart that
deviseth wicked imaginations
feet that be swift and running to
mischief
a false witness that speaketh lies and
he that soweth discord among brethren
in the short list of seven things that
god hates
two amongst them are lying
[Music]
i think that's that that pretty much
summarizes it bro i think that's another
interesting point spanish you know we're
good we left at the end because it
wasn't necessary bro if you think about
it you know making it
wasn't yeah it wasn't but you know you
have to understand that sometimes you
need to be coherent and consistent you
can't be a victim of your own criticism
so apply the same criticism to the
biblical god my friend right
god hates god hates someone who's who's
god hates the liar right what hates the
liar bro the the person who who who what
does false witness or something
so uh you square the circle doctor will
you name craig please
craig needs to be careful you're not
gonna say it but i'm gonna say it
you know you're very careful that you're
not lying especially about islamic
tradition we're not saying he is
but he has to at least do his research
when he's speaking about islam and the
love of god
in islam that being said brothers and
sisters two things two calls to action
number one
share this with william craig get this
out to him so we can make that actual
debate happen between hamza and craig
dr craig and secondly bro
you'll be shocked last thing you know
when i was going through doing a bit of
research yesterday on google
so many christian missionaries are
taking woody name craig's argument this
argument about the love of allah being
not perfect etc in islam or deficient
and writing blog posts and
and all of these essays and all of these
things online so many of them same
narrative
bro brothers and sisters make sure you
push this video this is the starting
point of getting the correct narrative
out then shall i push this video
which brother adam rasheed's video that
he's done on his channel which was also
absolutely
it takes a different perspective and
yeah that's it anything comes up
last things you want to say bro before
we wrap up well i i wouldn't want to
have a debate with craig i want to have
a conversation with him i think that's
very important
and hopefully in the future we're going
to be writing about this topic in
specific response to
dr craig's perspective on the concept of
god in the christian tradition islamic
tradition
and you know anything we've said that is
wrong anything that we said that is
inaccurate
has come from our egos has come from
shaitaan anything that is good has come
from
al-wudud the loving lord al-rahman the
intensely merciful lord
especially merciful lord and everyone
needs to remember that
may allah bless every single one of you
allah guide every single one of you
may all of you be showered and enveloped
in god's intense mercy
and his boundless love this is the
islamic
tradition
foreign